Nate is on the line in Phoenix welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Nate hey how are
you there
better than I deserve how can I help hey
I've got a question that I feel like I
should know the answer to I've been
listening to you for like 12 13 years
and surprisingly I don't know my own
answer
so I own my own business and I'm trying
to figure out first of all I'm on baby
step 4 4 5 & 6 I'm trying to figure out
if I should be doing 15% of my gross or
my net I guess question 1 but I've got
kind of a follow-up to that okay
the it gross before taxes not gross
revenues okay Cibola income not
after-tax income so when I ask someone
what their household income is they tell
me before taxes typically sometimes or
they'll say after tax either one and
I'll convert it back while I'm talking
to them if you've been listening if you
heard me do that so if you mean if you
say I make $100,000 that means you your
business made a profit of $100,000 but
you hadn't yet paid your federal income
tax and that would be 15% of that number
is what we're recommending and maybe
step 4 okay so that part I was on I was
on point so I thought that was correct
so my follow-up is so based off of my
income 15% I'm I can't get to 15%
because I'm maxed on all of my so we
have fully funded symbols from my wife
and I and we have fully funded our rocks
that we have been done a back door so
with that we still have room to go and I
don't know how to get there because as
far as I know the only thing above to
play what 18 19,000 and your simple yeah
okay and your wife working for the
business as well yeah so you put you put
38 in there right okay and to backdoor
Ross so another 13s or 41 so you're
making Bank baby
right and that yes so what are you
making like 400 grand yeah yeah okay for
you absolutely awesome man good for you
well here's the thing you're not gonna
go broke saving forty five thousand
dollars a year you're gonna be a
millionaire just doing that very quickly
right that's pretty substantial savings
in just those two government accounts
the simples and the Roth's and you can
set the symbols up as Roth's - I think
can't you I know I don't I don't think
so um I think you can you might want to
check on that but I may be wrong that's
aside nuance in the discussion okay but
what can you do after that you've maxed
out all that's available to you it's
that simple in terms of tax protected
retirement plans the only other thing
you could do to get to 15% would be to
just invest in some mutual funds and
what I do there and I'm in the same boat
you're in is I actually use for my
shorter term investing no load index
funds because I'm not investing for the
long term I'm gonna roll that over into
real estate after it gets enough in
there okay so I'll take just an S&P 500
fund because it has a low turnover ratio
even if you don't go that route look for
low turnover ratio and here's why here's
what that means the turnover ratios how
many times they sell the stocks inside
the mutual funds in a year so if they
had a 50 percent turnover ratio that
means I sell half the stocks in a year
which activates all the capital gains on
those stocks if you own the mutual fund
and it's not in a retirement account
okay and we're not in one we're out
we're out in the cold here that we're
talking about so if you had a low
turnover ratio meaning they sold almost
none of the stocks a year like 3%
turnover ratio okay which which an index
fund is an easy book place to find that
like an S&P 500 it'll have a 3/4 percent
turnover ratio that means that the
stocks are growing and they're and
they're not activating the capital gains
because they held them it's like buying
an individual stock or a rental
pretty if you bought a share of stock
for $50 and it goes up to $70 you don't
pay taxes on the $20 until you sell it
and that's all this is they're not
selling it so you're not paying taxes on
it
see you in effect have tax deferred gain
and if you hold it at least a year it's
gonna be capital gains rate which in
your case in my case is 20 percent so if
I'm saving then when I have enough
because I do are buy real estate I'm in
real estate so one is I just use that
account and when I get like a couple
hundred grand in there I'll go buy a
property okay and do you pay any sort of
when you pull that out do you pay taxes
at that time capital gains on whatever
you pull out if you've left it in there
at least a year if you didn't leave it
in there a year it's gonna be ordinary
income on your gain which your butt
kicked on that but there's no penalty
because it's just a it is a capital gain
tax and it will be you know if you're
over 400 it's 20% so your but still less
than what you're paying on taxes your
taxes are 40% almost so you know it's
still half leave it in there a year let
it grow and that's only on the gain
you've already paid taxes it's an
after-tax investment there's no shelter
on it at all but it but if you left it
alone ten years and it went up a million
dollars you don't pay taxes on that gain
until you cash it out just like if you
own a rental house and it goes from
200,000 to 300,000 in value you don't
pay taxes on that hundred thousand
dollar gain until you cash it out and
what tax people call realized versus
recognized
it's a realized gain but it is not
recognized because I'm not activated
that tax with the sale okay so your only
thing what you were talking about with
the with the low turnover you're only
paying whatever your active or your
capital gains would be would be only if
it's turning over during that time other
than that you don't pay anything until
you check it out yeah okay and and if
you held it at least a year your taxes
on the gain are only going to be 20% not
40% like your income is so it's a great
man it's a great deal and I use that
tool all the time to save
to buy a piece of ground or the office
building or another piece of property or
something and that's my my real estate
thing and consequently what's ended up
happening is I've ended up with more
money in real estate than I have a
mutual funds just because of its gotta
not belong over that direction but it's
kind of fun let's go I love real estate
so it's easy for me to do that and if
you want to just leave it in there if
you like mutual funds better you just
leave it in there let it grow that's
okay too
but at least you've still got tax
deferred growth effectively because it's
a capital gains type growth and you're
not paying taxes on the until you cash
it out and when you do it's only an
ordinary income that's better than any
annuity product out there because the
new 'ti products when you catch them out
are all taxed at ordinary income so this
is a really sweet strategy and when
you're killing it like you are man way
to go I'm so proud of you great job man
obviously doing a great job in the
marketplace very well done